Oh Shay you worked on getting everything
just right like your dad's hairstyle
from the 80s you got that down as well
let's take a look at your dad's from the
80s Eleonora said I look like Sheila E
right one of the debarge's there yeah
exactly what about the the jerry curl
did it make you respect the jerry curl
style when you tried the jerry curl is
it's almost like you know that's
Superman's cape you know what's that
once I'll put it on you know the
transformation really starts to happen
and then you start to you know you
really start to feel it so you know the
jerry curl was definitely popping this
because it's a period piece and if
you're further into the 80s but it's the
only thing that's changed about my dad
since then so he had to go curl
activator makes you do gangster rap just
a little bit so would you ever go back
to the jheri curl look would you only
have you rock one out rock
I would do it elbow we should do that we
should go together and get jheri curl
what about it yeah we sit up in the
salon together let's do that we're gonna
do that alright that's that's a deal
right there you'll be paid nothing hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography